[Música]
[Aplausos]
es mayo de 2018
piso 4 de un edificio en parís
es primavera afuera la gente disfruta
pero adentro desde decisión piso 4 con
la ventana abierta
se encuentra un chico
solo
perdido
sin ganas de vivir
los demás quién soy
no sé a dónde voy
al menos se saltó algo va a pasar
este chico era yo
fue el episodio más doloroso de toda mi
vida
buenas noches
soy usual soy francés
tengo
tengo 29 años y vivo aquí en el cuarto
escondido la vida de mis sueños
hoy me gustaría compartir con ustedes un
mensaje de esperanza
tengo una pequeña teoría que se llama
el regalo escondido
pero antes voy a compartir un poco más
sobre
mi vida mi pequeño camino en este mundo
soy un viajero
nací en ver xal una ciudad cerca de
parís
pero cuando tenía seis meses seguí a mis
padres
para mi bien en la fecha
vivimos dos años en burundi y seis años
en campo
me acuerdo muy bien de esta vida era una
vida llena de amor de alegría y de
muchas experiencias siempre estábamos
buscando para vivir nuevas cosas
a la edad de 8 años
si otra vez mis padres
para vivir en una pequeña isla francesa
que se llama de niño
está cerca de sudáfrica y madagascar
mi padre era profesor de francés
me acuerdo muy bien cuando llegamos en
esta pequeña isla
es parte de francia pero tiene también
su propia cultura su propio dialecto y
cuando llegue a la escuela los primeros
días tenía que aprender este dialecto
hablando con mis amigos
pero después de algunos miedos me
acuerdo muy bien que me encantó esta
sensación
viví una vida
muy feliz en esta pequeña isla durante
12 años
cuando tenía 18 años tenía que pensar un
poco más en el futuro
elegir mis estudios por eso empecé a
hablar con mi familia mis amigos
a tener más ideas
finalmente
decidí de estudiar en una escuela de
negocios
por eso me fui en 2010 a vivir en una
ciudad cerca de parís que se llama
me acuerdo muy bien que esta ciudad y
este tiempo era un buen momento para mí
tenía mucha libertad siempre estaba
encontrando nuevas personas construyendo
nuevos proyectos me sentí muy libre
también seguí a viajar fui a vivir
durante seis meses en chino
pero otra vez tenía que elegir que iba a
ser de mi vida que trabajo y mis padres
estaban preocupados pero preguntando
y afortunadamente
teníamos la carta de trabajo antes de
tener mi diploma en una grande empresa
de
consulting en parís y otra vez estaba
muy feliz estaba muy feliz porque
estaba muy fácil de compartir esta
información con toda mi familia y mis
amigos yo estaba muy orgulloso y todos
estaban muy orgullosos
empecé muy viernes de trabajo todo
funcionó bien tenía una alguna vida
tenía esta impresión que toda esta edad
muy posible
pero poco a poco
después de algunos años empecé a
sentirme un poco mal
como si faltó algo un poco de sentido
tal vez de viajes faltó algo y yo no
sabía realmente cómo empezar un cambio
siempre estaba siguiendo mi vida mi
pequeña rutina del país
tenía solamente que está feliz y seguir
esta vida más
después de esta experiencia y de seis
años de trabajo en esta empresa
llegué a este punto de mayo de 2018
[Aplausos]
renunciar y trabajo en noviembre de 2018
y primera idea era de buscar un lugar en
línea donde podría donde el clima fuera
agradable
donde podría empezar a poder empezar a
aprender un nuevo idioma
donde pudiera empezar a aprender a
surfear
y después de algunas búsquedas encontré
cuarto escondido
llegué en febrero de este año
y todo mi encanto ha hecho
llegué por dos semanas de vacaciones y
hace nueve meses
ay
soy un flyer estoy viviendo aquí la vida
de mis sueños
tengo varias actividades aquí en el
cuarto escondido y fuera del país
en el estado de oaxaca somos muy
afortunados de vivir en el corazón del
musical
antes de llegar al cuarto yo no conocía
el mezcal
ahora puedo decir que me encanta la
cultura mexicana
y me encanta estar
por eso ayude a iniciar el servicio que
se llama puerto o mezcal tours para
compartir
mi pasión por el mezcal con los turistas
y las personas que quieren aprender más
sobre el mezcal
estoy convencido que el mestral
es un buen vehículo para compartir la
cultura mexicana
aqui en mexico y también fue fuera del
país
inicia también un otro proyecto que hago
en línea
es de coche
compartió un poco mi camino y mi
experiencia y muy rápidamente y que
podría ayudar a algunas personas
a empezar algo en su vida
por eso muy naturalmente empecé esta
pequeña actividad en línea
y ahora voy a compartir un otro proyecto
que tengo aquí en puerto escondido que
ahora se llama green wild problema
y voy caminando en la playa zicatela
me entristece todo el plástico que
recolectó
después de algunas semanas empecé a
pensar cómo podría ser
ayuda puerto escondido hacer un lugar
con menos plástico
fui otra vez a buscar en línea y
encontré una plataforma que se llama
first plastic
y queda toda la información para
construir una máquina para reciclar el
plástico
me inscribí en esta plataforma
con suerte mucha suerte y alguien que
estaba trabajando aquí en puerto
escondido sobre este proyecto
encontré esta persona
y muy rápidamente nos organizamos para
desarrollar este proyecto
la idea es de recolectar el plástico
triturarlo fundirlo y construir nuevas
agujetas
ahora somos al principio de este
proyecto pero somos un equipo de cinco
personas tenemos todas las partes de la
primera máquina para triturar el
plástico
y ahora nos faltan solamente un lugar
donde instalar esta máquina
los próximos pasos son esos un lugar y
después construir esta máquina y empezar
esta primera actividad
entonces siempre buscamos nuevas ideas
nuevas personas que tienen ideas porque
quieren darse un poco de tiempo en este
proyecto
por eso puse nuestra página en instagram
y mi correo electrónico para contestar a
preguntas o hablar más sobre este
proyecto
quiero regresar
en el rellano escondido
y está viviendo la vida de mis sueños
pero hoy puedo decir que encontré mi
regalo escondido aquí en el cuarto
escondido
este episodio de 2018 fue el episodio
más doloroso de toda mi vida pero me
ayuda me ayudó a encontrar la vida de
mis sueños
entonces tengo esta pequeña teoría y ya
hace algunos años que la compartí con
mis amigos y mi familia del carro
qué significa el regalo escondido
significa que intentaba la experiencia
de nuestras vidas
la vida también nos ayuda a encontrar
nuestro propio regalo
y ahora estoy convencido que siempre
existe un regalo para las personas que
quieran buscarlo
me gustaria
y compartir con ustedes este mensaje
para que la próxima vez que
vivan un momento difícil en su vida
recuerden que los llevará a encontrar su
reinaron escondido muchas gracias
[Aplausos]